this video is only for those of you that
love competition you want to make a name
for yourself you want to compete in a
Marketplace maybe even you want to be a
dominator you want to be somebody that
people are saying this guy is kicking
some major ass in the industry he or she
is a part of let me talk to you if you
get value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
you know my favorite season of the year
is November whatever it is a day before
Thanksgiving to the first week of
January here's why that season produces
more people getting casual that become
casualties than any other season
including summer a night a day before
Thanksgiving till about second week of
January people are Thanksgiving mode
they're coming in later they're going
home earlier they're kicking back
they're relaxing they're calling in sick
on Fridays and Mondays and all this I've
been around the block and I've watched
and I saw so many of the people that
were way ahead of me when I was a brand
spanking new salesperson when I was a
small agency running my insurance office
when I was running a company I watched
everybody I'm gonna say wow that guy
kicked my ass for 10 and a half months
but he takes these six weeks off and
it's so interesting why he does that so
what happens during that season that is
your season to catch up you recreate
yourself you realize what new skill sets
you want to learn what new topics you
want to study what new habits you want
to pick up you go buy the courses you go
buy the books you go take the seminars
you go do certain zooms everybody who is
competing at the highest level they do
certain things others aren't willing to
do you may watch this video right now
and you don't even like this video
because you're like well Pat why are you
saying this to me it's Christmas I'm
supposed to take the time off I'm
supposed to be kicking back don't you
take Christmas off don't you take
Thanksgiving don't you do any of this
stuff yes I do but I have a different
mindset around it I was being
interviewed by another uh podcaster
YouTuber and he's here interviewing me
up so Sean Cannell he says Patrick you
agreed to do the podcast with me today
I'm interviewing you I flew out to
Florida interview but today is your
birthday I said yeah he says why are you
at the office I said what's the big deal
it's your birthday it's another day for
me what do you mean let me explain it to
you if the government tells me what days
to take off that means the government's
my boss the government doesn't dictate
what days I take off I decide what days
I take off because I'm a leader I don't
need you to tell me it's Memorial
Weekend take Monday off I don't need you
to tell me it's Labor Day but I don't
need you to tell me it's Thanksgiving I
don't need you to tell me any of that
stuff you know where I was Thanksgiving
the day after Thanksgiving Friday I was
here all day and I have my kids here
with me you know where I was at Saturday
I brought him in here my kids are
watching daddy working they're like wow
daddy it's normal to them and we're
spending time together if one of them
had to write a phrase 75 times and the
other one had to write another phrase 75
times one of them had to write both of
the phrases 75 times we're working on
ourselves we're doing a bunch of
different things but this is your season
and by the way those of you who were
already planning on checking out guess
what you're about to get passed up and
you know who you are because you
probably stopped watching a video but
those of you guys that are still glued
to the screen and you're like hell yeah
you're talking to me phenomenal let's go
compete because the stars who are all of
a sudden identified in 2023 are the
people who behind closed doors during
this season are improving themselves and
if that's you 2023 is probably going to
be the beginning of the greatest years
of your life if you got value out of
this message give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to find out how to reach your full
potential video I did about three or
four years ago you've never seen it
before click here to watch that video
take care everybody bye